Maxine Waters is unhinged yet again the
anti-trump Democrats about it waters
defended her comments well I think that
most people who have watched me over the
past two years know that I am a
responsible person who have talked about
the Constitution they know that I've
been serious about this I've had the
courage to stand up when nobody else was
standing with me so people know that I'm
responsible and that I'm serious and
like I said that impeachment is the
imperative and tried to figure this out
after saying the president should be
behind bars waters is claiming it's
Trump who is putting her in danger he's
a president of the United States of
America he's setting some of us up to be
killed
I have death threats constantly their
number of people who have been convicted
but threatening to kill me
I mean I can't go to the grocery store
anymore by myself I have to pay for
security all the time I can't move
around the country without security so
Jessie this is the same woman who said
that Trump cabinet members should be
harassed in public while they're eating
out or at the grocery store so it's a
little bit ironic to hear her
complaining yeah first of all no one
wants a civil war and I think the
Republicans are undefeated in civil wars
just a little refresher course for those
of you guys who forgot you know Maxine
Waters no relation I know her pretty
well and I used to be a Booker for many
many years and I understand Maxine I
understand why people book her she's
crazy and occasionally you need to book
a crazy people on cable to keep the
audience interested because you never
know what she's gonna say and that's the
delightful part about people like her on
through and everybody named water and so
this is what they do they put her on
MSNBC and then they just let her go and
who knows what's gonna happen right yeah
I'd like Alan Grayson people like that
you know it's just crazy people right so
this is what they do
so the crazy people have three cards
they play they play the race card they
play the gender card and they play the
death card so now the death card it used
to be Republican policies kill people
right right
repealing Obamacare is going to kill you
all that stuff now Republican rhetoric
will kill you build the wall will get
people killed you know whatever gets
everybody killed so this is why they do
that though okay they try to tee it up
so the next time there is violence in
the country they can blame Trump they
also do this to make themselves feel
better about themselves like they're so
important that they might actually get
killed there's no kill list I get death
threats all the time and I'm a wonderful
person from me it also creates fear in
the electorate that Trump is rhetoric is
so dangerous you can't afford a second
term and it also insulates themselves
from criticism because hey you can't
criticize me because people are trying
to kill me right so Greg how do you feel
about Abraham Lincoln that's interesting
question Republican who wants a reward
ah he was a good guy a little too tall
for my tastes back story I won't get
into with him but anyway
Maxine kind of symbolizes the hypocrisy
of the entire left and the media in
general only we then the media can be
hostile right they don't want to share
the ball and then they own the feet I've
always said this before that's what I'm
trying to say in it they they own the
field they own the wraps they own the
equipment how dare Trump show up and
beat them at their own game you know
they never had this it reminds me a lot
of when when Fox News showed up and
everybody was going oh my god there's
this polarization no you will he liked
it when there was one pole right and
then you got another pole and now you
got to deal with that and it's just not
fair you don't want what you have to
work harder to defend your beliefs and I
think that's what the problem is as for
the you know the death threats we all
get the death threats and that's just
part of the game there's a lot of crazy
people out there and there's a lot of
new avenues to go after people it's very
simple the bar is low for people to do
that but I think it's a I think it's
healthy that for both sides that there
are now two sides and you can't be
complaining about it so Dana what are
your thoughts on well I mentioned at the
top but that Pelosi deputizing Adam
Schiff might not be the best solution
but it might be better than having
Maxine Waters out talking about it
because Nancy Pelosi is trying to be
very measured if you listen to any of
her commentary she peppers it with
things like we need to be thoughtful
about the call
so tushy we need to pray for the
president we need to be working on the
important work that the people want us
to deal with we have to work on the
trade deal infrastructure gun control
she in lowering drug prices and she
wants to do all of these things while
she's gonna be very measured and then
you have Maxine Waters who says actually
he should be killed or to be in solitary
confinement
the thing you have to wonder about is
imagine being a member of Congress for
that many years and no one taking you
seriously at all yeah one do you take
Maxine water seriously as a very nice
person
oh yes and let me just say wow she was
ahead of the curve on impeachment and
yet you don't hear people say they say
oh it's the moderates she's ahead of the
curve she was saying all along these
were impeachable offenses but here's the
mic you're running and you said see we
like Booker's like to get I think what
you said was crazy which i think is
offensive I don't think that lady's
crazy she's not officially amazing
elections an elected member of Congress
or her constituents unless you're saying
her voters no I don't think that's nice
but anyway I think that in fact one
description your office because she was
mentally ill you say they would like to
invite people like her on the last few
days I've heard from one person talk
about civil war spies treason suggestion
that you're gonna have someone executed
profanity in a text it seems to me Trump
is performing he's energized and this is
going to be an epic brawl yeah okay so
numbers are through the roof right now
yeah through the floor